[Music]
reject nation its III week and we're
coming at you again I'm my name's John
that's how we do this right and with me
is Olivia Christine come to join me you
played some doom right good because
we're gonna take a look at the new doom
trailer but I'm pretty excited about
this I play a little bit of the reboot
and that was an experience and a half so
I'm pretty excited to see this franchise
continue on all the games out there that
have benefited from a modern game tech I
feel like stuff like doom and
Wolfenstein or among the great just like
yeah just the range of what you can do
to make that format crazier is just it
scratches a niche for me so I'm excited
for this let's check it out we Space
Marine again or no oh
oh yeah
I am excited
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh I'm excited yeah you know the choice
to go with like a slow tracking shot you
know over this hellish wasteland really
captured the gravitas
I expect radiant shades of black brown
and red huge brain yeah
there's endless mileage you can get from
me anyway with doom and just the endless
variety of hellish imp creatures and
yeah like this so much that I've never
wanted to go back and examine something
as like horrifying is this as much as I
do right now cuz there's you are doing
this kind of yeah that's Lohan really
does kind of add an ironic twist to this
trailer because the last one the reboot
trailer I remember being just bowled
over by how much carnage and how much
yeah they really led with that and this
is like still in your face but just with
a different mood in the motion in a way
yeah it's like if you were just stepping
into this world for the first time and
kind of getting acquainted with it yeah
yeah cuz it feels like you're really
walking around I feel like there are a
lot of games I feel like would be really
scary in VR and doom would still be
scary but I feel like I would still have
a chance I would have to be precise at
anything you're just killing everything
around you mash that trigger down and
take down those beans I hope you get to
fight that brain creature or whatever
that is and some of these like horrible
tentacle monsters and whatever do you
might feel like it's just one of those
games that has like a classic yeah it's
just got its thing and it does it well
yeah there are so many awesome trailers
that have been dropping just today alone
I've been really wowed by a lot of the
imagery and a lot of the different
things we've been seeing but watching it
doom trailer just always brings me back
yeah I just get giddy
I get like remember my mom you can't
play that without hearing on my little
laptop with that little card it's a good
way to let off some steam because you
got all that heavy metal
this is like the medallist game of all
time
yeah if you need if you need to get some
some of your rage out in a constructive
way I feel I could do is probably just a
good therapeutic tool for you but yeah
what did you guys think hit us up in the
comment box leave us your thoughts and
as always you can subscribe to the real
Rejects click that notification bell cuz
you know the subscribe button who really
worked that well and follow olivia
christine on the instagrams that forever
Tiffany's and or don't you know it's a
you're a free we'll have in person but
you know what you you you don't have a
choice in is to come join us on patreon
because we got a full-length watch
alongs we got video that we got music
video reactions we get we got all sorts
of stuff and you're gonna love it I
promise so come on over there check us
out and as always people Cheers